انهى المجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر
اجتماعه دون اتخاذ قرار واضح بشان اليوم
التالي للحرب على غزه ونقلت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين رفعي
المستوى قولهم ان جميع المقترحات المقدمه
بشان الاسرى تؤدي في النهايه الى وقف
الحرب واضافت ان مجلس وزراء الحرب بحث
جهود استعاده الاسرى رغم الفجوات الكبيره
بين الطرفين وفق المسؤولين الذين اكدوا ان
على اسرائيل الان اتخاذ القرار اذا ما
كانت ستوافق على صفقه تؤدي الى انهاء
الحرب وانسحاب الجيش من غزه كما اشار
المسؤولون الى ان المقترح القطري لا يختلف
بشكل كبير عن المقترحات السابقه ويتضمن في
المرحله الاولى تبادل الاسرى على اساس
انساني وفي مرحلته الاخيره انسحاب الجيش
من
غزه